three I've been doing that he tastes
paper towels for everything on my action
I keep it clean on paper towels usually
Stephen think even though I said action
you guys are still going at it which
makes me want to ask you what is the
pettiest thing you guys have argued
about about a she's a [ __ ]
well that's no argument I am a [ __ ] Oh
Steve won yeah no I agree that she's a
[ __ ] oh I made the argument I'm a [ __ ]
okay and I was like you're not a [ __ ]
yeah she was I also you know you're just
arguing because um you know like
resources are limited right now because
of CO vide and Steve uses a [ __ ]
paper towel for everything everyday I'm
talking about this man like he's cooking
and he needs a paper towel to set his
spoon down on the counter yeah thank you
I use the [ __ ] spoon afterwards good
use a dish towel yo can your the plate
you can use a plate use a paper towel
and then when you're eating you use the
same paper towel to wipe your mouth
thank you to hear that's the other thing
recycle use a cloth napkin you can use a
clock that means how do you wash that oh
yeah at the wash thing that's better
you using water reuse it urgent on the
shelves laundry detergent is not sold
out hey you should tell me I got tons of
okay uh I don't tell them that they're
gonna come to our house order laundry
detergent like a week ago or something
and it's still not in so I'm like we
need to do laundry
some people say USPS make it shut down -
oh yeah all I keep hearing is the
[ __ ] craziest nutty's rumors but so
far everything seems to be in the same
thing is like we don't know what's gonna
happen so like we don't have a ton of
toilet paper because you know it's been
sold out forever and I'm luckily we did
get some we got a shipment right before
all of this closed be afraid
they don't respect it they respect it
I didn't hear you you didn't like the
movie there we go and we're only doing
that everybody because [ __ ] YouTube
do you monetize you if you say the
regular one so that you know that's
alright so now it's go watch that off
the record where we established it is it
weird if it cooking and you don't have a
pair but I'll just take a sock off so
you could rest your ladle on the sock
yeah yeah if you take your sanitary on a
clean side if we go to full lockdown use
my socks with this it's only unsanitary
if you put the sock back on thing ladle
with your mouth I'm saying if we're out
of toilet paper and out of paper towels
I would use a sock do i grass yeah
because you couldn't move you could get
a shower just gonna shower spray at the
to you right now been telling you guys
to get a birthday for years okay we're
not boozy we should have got a bidet you
shut up you shut up you can also look
some long grass that's an option okay
I'll do it all the time if we get there
we'll get there we don't have any lon no
long L Ong long grass oh the long ones
were fed in the show I thought I said
long dress too it's hard to tell the
difference between long and long yes
only what you say yeah you do it then
long if I looked it up on Wikipedia long
I said long see your lungs long long
grass he says long on no s long wait
were you saying long grass like yellow
ng okay how much how much toilet paper
would somebody have to pay you for you
to suck it did I have enough I have to
wear
no don't poke the guys though Oh while I
was doing those big Costco things really
that's a lot if I put a science head on
he would do it not for toilet paper
stocked up until probably River I've
talked of my house [ __ ] how much is that
money that too too big Costco size ones
how much that it's like $40,000 god that
40,000 oh yeah so that's surprise
well right now I'm talking about toilet
paper I don't give a [ __ ] about money
okay hey you can use money to wipe your
ass - oh that's true good point yeah
okay cash okay anyway no Martin how
about you with with Gio what's the
pettiest thing you think you've ever
argued about like the stupidest thing I
could give you some some of these uh
these examples and maybe I'll spark
something yeah cuz I feel like we argue
all the time I so know what they're
about cuz you're so dumb yes
I'm going to show you right now I was
getting ready yesterday do you have a
video of the argument I was getting
ready yesterday to go shoot and she ran
in the room and took my jacket right so
you wouldn't leave I'm looking for well
you block that's why I keep my t-shirts
oh that's cool
she hid it yes
she literally put it in there and I was
like I'm looking all up like 30 minutes
of to the look and she's just laughing
it's like is so good I want to tell you
but I'm enjoying this too much head like
she literally did not tell me I had to
light light I was like wait this
matching before I literally [ __ ] all
these ships up last night and I grabbed
it and [ __ ] stuff and this isn't a small
hole like it's like a real gold she just
stuffed it in I was like you outdo
yourself every [ __ ] day if you think
that's petty
that is very petty we got into argument
last night see was I was thinking if
Steve I was like
I love you I love you I love you I love
you I do and then I hid it right outside
the bathroom why do you do this maddie
was mad for hours no no it was like a
serial killer song it's like it's like
that other serial killer song of the
month Amanda Newman and my name it oh my
god didn't it turn all the circle movies
one of the favorite things me and Jill
used to love doing and it turned into an
all-out fight not like fight fight but
like a fight was when she's showering
and she loves hot water one of my
favorite things is to go in the kitchen
and get a pot of really cold water oh my
god I was right when I first sent it I
was like you a [ __ ] frat boy yeah
[ __ ] fractions I'm petty Frankie it's
just me you got you've got to scream and
I love you at you my wife always asked
me every time I leave while she leaves
you like bad did you miss me so much
today I was like oh yeah so much right
cuz like I don't I don't talk like that
well babe I missed you so this is not
what I do yeah I'll tell you when I tell
you but like the older and every time
you tell ask me I'm like oh yeah
babbling miss you so much love you so
much she's like you just lie to me so
where I'm like then why do you keep
asking me to hear it well you'll never
get it from me she's hoping that is true
yeah why do I miss you so much oh my god
yes oh
because I was showing other ways words
of affirmation is probably her love
language true physical touch in quality
time is a love language the words the
information that you have wha
yes yeah but just just like simple
things there's not that much right
listen you're my best friend person that
gets me the most of the world and yes
when what do you want
damn I said yes hey I said yes
[Laughter]
cultivating anything okay so I will read
some of these so number one I was sick
not to say what's happen yeah I got all
that dirt yeah [ __ ] I got going on tips
we argue about him you don't want to
know I want to know literally are you
running my pasta game their cokes are
petty members okay
no I'm telling Jenna hey that ain't
nothing it ain't really patty to much
true pay she gets mad and sleeps on the
couch because he PU I kept being on her
in the shower I didn't tell her like I
did she know what's happened cuz he
could smell it we were eating a lot of
asparagus at first it was a science
thing first it was like science at all
will she be able to tell the difference
and the the temperature and at first you
didn't know it wasn't like the second
times who like oh yeah because we've
done up like 30 videos now and I'm like
to hear [ __ ] game he's got some class
and then you take it all the way into
and a half video no one else class deep
apparently no no you're the classy guy
but you sure know last class
Steve would never you never hygienic as
person you won't even let me look at his
butt
but then you just complain about this
closet so I don't mean the shouts true
but that's not hygiene it's not personal
messiest [ __ ] person but cleanliness
personal hygiene uh-huh spotless
well I did it in the shower Nicky this
soap involved you would never never you
wouldn't kill well fart around me I've
been even led and you're anything going
on the bow well he doesn't fart around
you know that [ __ ] what the door opens
yeah I know but I gotta say sex drive is
up 100% my [ __ ] sex drive keeps going
up every year because this [ __ ] called
the Steve Reed method you can look it up
I literally hold her like I hold her
shoulders like to get the no part to
lock my hair and I fought under the
covers so she can't escape it I was a
skeptic because every other boyfriend we
farted in front of each other and I was
like this is kind of weird cuz I always
thought that meant comfort and all that
stuff
yes but I went with it and I got I'm a
believer now I'm a believer degree
method hasn't paid off for me Tom Brady
has is his method I got my cat the
method you're not doing the Heidi
Hartmann hygiene hygiene missing oven
full method so you know far different
habits is that she does important funny
that's what you keep thank you sleep
I'll she definitely get down you can't
help can we get the first one rule
thingy there but then we also awake each
other up in the sleep well I will only
read one there were 13 jesus christ we
are awful we're pettier than these
people Gary that's true only this is a
listicle
it was [ __ ] now it's just one and now
I'm looking through them all night which
one no you were you doing just just you
you go [ __ ] up you like click on the
lawyer here's the one number 10 on this
list is how to
[Music]
[Music]